bonjour joseph manès bonjour monsieur le
temps sans caddie accueille ce matin une
ancienne présidente du conseil général
on va vous comment on va commencer par
vous adresser tous nos voeux pour cette
année 2010 est josette manin le panais
vous qui aviez juré promis que la
politique ce serait fini que vous
occupez riez désormais de vos petits
enfants
votre retour ça veut dire quand un élu
quand tu n'es du dic qui s'en va awa
faut pas nous croise à monsieur viol
temps avant de vous répondre je vais
d'abord demandé aux dozos du tueur
d'excusés ma voix je les ai perdus non
pas dans la bringue mais simplement par
la grippe qui court en ce moment je
remercie pour ses voeux mais avant tout
dégraisser à la population martiniquaise
tous les voeux de santé et beaucoup
d'amour pour cette année 2010 est alors
le come back de manas alors le come back
de man est simple 1 je crois que maurice
viol ton en a parlé il ya quelques jours
mais je vous dépendez quelques
précisions je ne jure jamais monsieur
viol ton jeu le jeu que devant dieu sur
les choses qui touchent à ma foi et
c'est vrai que il y a quelques mois
je vais lui 18 mois j'avais pris du
recul
j'avais demandé à ne pas m'inscrire sur
la liste concernant les élections de la
ctm parce que je ne souhaitais pas y
être
et j'avais demandé également de me
laisser quelques temps le vent vous
laisse tranquille avec les affaires
publiques exactement il exagéré j'étais
fatigué pas du tout pas du tout j'avais
peut-être
j'avais envie de revenir à des choses
simples simplement parce que trente
années de politique j'en veux dire même
32 années de politiques à un moment
donné une mère de famille a besoin de
voir autre chose
elle a besoin de sentir autre chose elle
a besoin effectivement de s'occuper
d'elle-même parce qu'il faut se dire que
que ce soit un homme que ce soit une
femme quand on se lève le matin et qu'on
s'en va et qu'on ne sait pas quelle
heure on revient on ne sait pas où sont
ces enfants mais tout ça vous a manqué
puisque vous revenez alors qu'est ce qui
vous a convaincu
simplement parce qu'après une année j'ai
pris le temps de bien faire les choses
de bien préparer les choses de bien me
préparer
il doit vous dire surtout que c'était
dans votre adn que vous pouviez pas
passer à côté d'une opportunité
historique peut être devenir d'arriver à
la députation puisque le sortant alfred
marie-jeanne ne se représente pas le
parquet bâle a toutes les chances que ça
a certainement je ne vais pas mentir il
ya un peu de ça justement si on pour le
temps de réfléchir en six ans la peau
vous prend le temps de faire une analyse
d'une situation donnée vous parle
effectivement de
de monsieur marie jeanne qui se retire
on se dit mais pourquoi pas moi oui
pourquoi ne pas y aller je voulais dit
le parquet baril est plus là il ya plus
de gros mordant face à vous c'est la
voie royale pour vous même à passau
sipac là bas mais s'il bat mali sotelma
tout cas hier avec tous temps en tous
cas sur votre route il dresse à fabrice
du nom que vous avez connu à l'époque de
de bâtir le pays martinique au sein du
conseil municipal laventinois c'est un
écueil gros qu'il faudra éviter pour
vous je veux avant de parler de fabrice
nous mais j'ai pas l'intention d'en
parler global adversaires je veux
simplement dire aussi je veux porter une
précision que j'entends depuis quelques
temps les gens viennent me dire comment
tu vas comment va ta santé est ce que ça
va mieux je n'ai jamais été malade comme
les gens le prix tendent
je suis malade comme tout martiniquais
c'est à dire que bien l'extérieur et
puis peut-être malades à l'intérieu mais
joseph mané secours soviétiques n'ont
pas du tout pas du tout à cause de
certains de certains phénomènes de
certains vieillissement la gtz et
josette manin
qu'est ce qui vous a vraiment permis de
revenir c'est surtout ces rejets
chimiques et s'est montré très pressant
auprès de vous non pas du tout je ne
dépends pas moins de sièges letchimy non
moi je suis mauvais d'invités lors du
congrès salle immense de martiniquais
absolue parce que justement et les yeux
doux quand même n'ayant pas été présente
pendant le les élections de la ctm ayant
fait quelques observations sur justement
ces élections ayant pris du recul et on
réfléchit ayant discuté avec des
camarades du rhdp m
de bâtir le pays martinique il serge de
chimie a trouvé bon effectivement
d'écouter un petit peu l'analyse que je
pouvais faire d'une situation donnée
des résultats des élections et pour cela
mais en tant que membre de bâtir le pays
martinique m'a demandé de venir faire
une intervention tout côte lors de la
convention de dupes et ont considéré
cela comme étant déjà la lune de miel
entre vous et serge est finie nous avons
toujours été en lune de miel serge
letchimy et moi n'en déplaise à certains
josette manin vous aller à cette
élection de juin prochain pour la
législative dans le centre atlantique
sur quels thèmes vous allez bataille et
on se rappelle quand même que votre
équipe ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle a quand même perdu la bataille
de la ctm sur des arguments très très
simple pour vos adversaires de l'époque
vous ne savez pas gérer vous n'avez rien
fait pour développer le pays et vous sur
quoi vous et faire campagne mais coûté
une élection ne ressemble pas à une
autre élection de la ctm d'ailleurs je
n'ai pas pris par an pour éviter
justement d'entendre tout ce que vous
êtes en train de dire
les élections ne se ressemblent pas
l'élection de la ctm quoi qu'on dise
c'est une élection qui a été préparé par
nous prépare les parents semblent
martinique nouvelle préparé par
l'exécutif que j'ai été au conseil
général parce qu'il ya eu un travail de
cinq ans qui a été fait préparé par le
conseil régional mené par serge letchimy
et nous pensions effectivement que ce
que nous avions fait pendant ces années
pendant ces cinq années où j'y étais
pendant ces six années où serge letchimy
était au conseil régional pour situer
effectivement un avoir à extrêmement
important un travail extrêmement
important fait résultat c'était ben ali
le peuple n'a pas voulu dans sa majorité
alors aujourd'hui sur quelle base
allez-vous repartir mais ont été réduire
le peuple très souvent ne regarde pas
les résultats mais regarde les hommes
les hommes et les femmes je vais dire
donc vous avez des idées des gens qui
savent séduire
vous avez des gens qui savent
certainement
passé chez monsieur untel ou monsieur ou
madame e t elle faire des promesses
peut-être que c'est ce que ça dépend de
la manière ça dépend comment on le fait
donc j'estime simplement que cette
élection à l'assemblée nationale ne
ressemble en rien à l'élection donc de
la cité m
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
commence à travailler donc avec la lampe
ou une martinique nouvelle sur un tronc
commun concernant l'ensemble des
candidats de l'enseignement technique
nouvelle sur effectivement des éléments
concernant d'autres la circonscription
que ce que je vais défendre à savoir une
circonscription qui est composé de 4 4,5
communiqué extrêmement important et je
rappelle que nous avons le lamantin
grosses communes nous avons le robert
nous avons le françois nous avons
trinité et je n'oublie pas le goût monde
donc j'estime que nous avons c'est que
comme une importante qu'il faut séduire
j'ai l'intention de séduire à nouveau la
montée déjà par le choix du client le
choix du suppléant est important parce
que j'estime qu'un suppléant n'est pas
quelqu'un qui sur une affiche qui
figurent simplement sur une affiche ou
faire beau suppliant et là par sa
capacité effectivement à travailler sur
le terrain avec le candidat par sa
capacité à ramener la population donc de
son territoire par par sa capacité à
convaincre cette population si elle
n'est pas convaincue par nounou
candidature donc c'est comme ça que le
choix se fait alors qu'est ce que qui
vous allez choisir vous comment vous
allez décider
est ce que c'est manas qui a la main là
dessus ou bien c'est que je veux donner
aux coupes semaine à valence cours mais
simplement parce que non il ya un safari
nous nous y travaillons monsieur
violente on n'avançait pas des noms vous
me mettez en difficulté la problématique
la problématique est la suivante
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
nous laisse libres de choisir nos
suppléants une autre suppléant on le
mien tout tout tout autant que selon le
les résultats l'eau qui déciderait au ce
sera serge chibi non pas du tout serge
letchimy n'a rien à décider
il y à un échange qui sera fait d'abord
d'abord au comité de bâtir le pays
martinique
je rappelle que jusqu'à maintenant je
suis membre du comité national de bâtir
le pays martinique que nous avons notre
prochaine réunion demain comme tous les
mardis soir de façon à pouvoir
travailler sur les grands sujets il a le
sujet est important il y attend donc à
bien fonctionner en revanche cette manne
et david zobda je termine monsieur
violente en disant qu' il y aura donc
effectivement une échange qui savent qui
sera fait au sein de mon parti politique
sur la désignation sur une proposition
ou des propositions pour cécilia mais
non bien ça mon pack a décidé tout seul
personne ne décide seul dans un parti
politique il y a quand même une
concertation allocs nous et des béni oui
oui qui ça non
nous avons l'habitude de travailler
ensemble sinon c'est pas la peine qu'on
se voit régulièrement donc le mardi soir
on est en réunion
donc on échange on partage et on propose
on décide donc il y aura donc des
propositions entreprendra des échanges
et on n'en fera pas un swing martinique
nouvelle de façon à valider on offre à
parle d'abord à eau supplions que nous
aurons proposé on aura certainement une
réunion de travail avec eux parce que
comme je disais il faut que le suppliant
nous apporte sa contribution
je les dis un suppléant ne vient pas
simplement pour faire beau et qu'il pèse
devoir amener il faut qu'il pèse il faut
qu'il travaille surtout il ya une
campagne électorale à venir
donc il faut que ce supplément ou sept
suppléants travail donc on ne fait pas
venu quelqu'un comme ça parce que c'est
monsieur untel parce qu'il appartient
tellement
imaginez par exemple le rapprochement
entre josette manin et raphaël vaugirard
du beau monde de la fsm jusqu'à nouvel
ordre je n'ai pas d'information de la
venue de raphaël vosges et rhin
je suppose parce que nous nous sommes
deux d'anciens collègues du conseil
général nous avons rencontré très
récemment à trinité mais de toute façon
il y a aucune animosité entre qui que ce
soit et je le dis dès maintenant que la
campagne électorale sera une compagnie
oral avec le respect de chaque candidat
alors justement comment qu'il soit la
tonalité de cette campagne est ce que
vous avez vous évertuez à attaquer par
exemple le bilan du sortant qui ne se
représente pas à alfred marie jeanne
ou bien vous allez expliquer ce que vous
comptez faire tout simplement si
d'aventuré vous êtes retenu pour
l'assemblée nationale non je ne vis pas
pour critiquer qui que ce soit
nous avons aujourd'hui six
parlementaires quatre députés et de
sénateurs
il ya un travail qui a été cliqué fait
par l'ensemble de de ses parlementaires
je crois que chaque aujourd'hui peut
aller vérifier sur internet
le travail qui fait les rapports qui
sont qui sont présentés donc ce n'est
pas à moi de juger le travail qui fait
c'est la population en tunique est de
pouvoir juger ce que tel ou un tel a
fait ou n'a pas fait maintenant ce que
je vais faire je vais devant les
proposer mieux en mieux en mieux oui
parce que si vous voulez faire encore
plus pour votre pays la martinique
non mais de toute façon chaque vieillit
avec donc son lot de propositions chacun
vient avec des engagements
moi je viens avec un engagement parce
qu'il faut rappeler que un député ou une
députée ne vient pas justement pour
entendre le canal qui n'est pas fait la
route qui n'est pas fait pour ça que je
ne dis pas que voilà c'est un programme
municipal aujourd'hui le rôle du député
c'est quoi c'est d'être de voter les
lois
1 2 messieurs où tout surtout de
travailler dans les commissions et je
crois que c'est ça qui quittent kiki
extrêmement important pour débuter si on
est élu député et qu'on n'est pas
justement présent pour pouvoir
travailler
je ne dis pas uniquement pour la
martinique puisque le député ne va pas
travailler uniquement pour son pays
il va travailler pour voter des lois il
va travailler justement pour faire des
propositions
à travers donc les commissions donc
voilà l'engagement que je prends auprès
de cette population martiniquaise et
j'ai serré effectivement de convaincre
tout le monde de ma candidature est de
ceux que je vous jure j'irai proposait
donc à
un martinique merci d'avoir été ce matin
avec nos jackman ne rappelle que vous
êtes candidate la législatives dans la
circonscription du centre atlantique
josette manin candidate ensemble pour
une martinique nouvelle bonne journée
merci et bonne journée